hi there today we're going to look at 10
the animation mistakes you probably
missed while watching your favorite
movies if you didn't notice them before
don't feel bad
that's what we're here for let's take a
look The Lion King Disney's The Lion
King is the story about a young prince
in line to inherit the throne where he
will rule as king of the pride lands the
Sun will set on my time here and will
rise with you as the new king Simba asks
about the shadowy place in the distance
Mufasa tells him he must never go there
but being the curious lion cub that he
is Simba and his pal Nala venture into
the dark and mysterious elephant
graveyard against his father's wishes
and that's when he gets into some
serious trouble with a pack of hyenas
they chased the Cubs through the
boneyard and Simba claws one of them in
the face leaving some pretty bad scratch
marks but later the hyenas corner Simba
Nala and there are no claw marks there
isn't even a hint of a mark we found
another mistake in a different part of
the movie where Timon dresses off to do
the hula
he wears a colorful lei puts a big
flower on his head and dances to
distract the hyenas so Simba can sneak
back into the pride lands but when his
back is turned he's not wearing a lei or
a flower it magically appears when he
turns around Aladdin Aladdin is a tale
about a stubborn princess who challenges
the archaic ways of the patriarchy
Princess Jasmine is not interested in
being married off and won't stand for
arrogant princes in her palace so what
does her dad do he gives her a pet tiger
of course makes total sense there's a
scene at the beginning where a suitor
comes to visit Princess Jasmine we see
the prince stomping out of the palace as
her father the sultan asks it appears
that Rajah has ripped a tiger bite sized
hole in his pants revealing some very
funny underwear with harps printed all
over them the movie then cuts to Raja
who is holding a torn piece of those
very same heart designed underwear in
his mouth but if Raja had really ripped
Prince Achmed's Underpants our view of
his backside would have been much
different when he stormed out of the
palace
Raja would have only had the princes
purple pants in the
mouths but for comedies sake they use
the heart undies instead you tangled
tangled is the story of Rapunzel but
with a twist in the Disney movie
Rapunzel has a magical healing hair it
lights up when she sings and can make
those who touch it young again an evil
woman who disguised herself as
Rapunzel's mother uses her hair to keep
herself young she locks Rapunzel in a
tower so she could have access to her
own personal Fountain of Youth whenever
she wants but Rapunzel escapes with a
thief named Flynn Rider she eventually
learns to love adventure and Rapunzel
and Flynn fall in love during their
journey together it's such a touching
moment when Rapunzel tries to save Flynn
and he liberate her by cutting off her
hair the scene is so touching we almost
didn't notice the major animation a
mistake when Flynn is lying on the floor
wounded and Rapunzel runs to his side
Flynn is clearly shackled with little
chance of escape from the tower but
during the close up when he caresses her
hair his wrist is suddenly unshackled
but when they cut to the wider shot of
the two characters Flynn's wrist is back
in shackles even Disney makes mistakes
sometimes and despite this animation
mishap it's still a great movie Shrek we
all love the animated fantasy adventure
comedy about the reclusive ogre named as
Shrek and his annoying talking donkey
friend donkey and Strax
team up to rescue a princess from a
flirtatious fire-breathing dragon
problem is the princess has a deep dark
secret the movie teaches us that ogres
are like onions you know because of
their layers and because they're both
stinky of course after they rescue
Princess Fiona they are attacked by
Robin Hood and his Merry Men in the
forest they battle after an impressive
dance number and Fiona shows off her
ninja warrior skills but if you watch
the scene closely you'll see an
animation mistake towards the end Shrek
and Donkey are amazed by Fiona
and when Shrek drops donkey and follows
Fiona his backside is completely free of
any arrows cut to a couple of seconds
later when Fiona points out
what how did that get there it's
possible that the animators miss this
when creating a scene however it's more
likely that they made the creative
choice to hide the arrow from the
audience until the perfect moment for
comedic effect Zootopia Zootopia is a
comedic animated Disney film about two
unlikely partners who also happened to
be animals
not to mention predator and prey the
film points to racism and discrimination
by creating a society where predator and
prey live peacefully together in a big
city
we learned that bunnies don't like to be
called cute and that foxes aren't always
what they seem in this scene Emmitt
Otterton 's wife is pleading with
officer Judy Hopps to find her missing
husband Emmitt she is holding up a
picture of Emmitt with his family to
show chief BOGO there's a cutaway to
Judi looking back at mrs. Otterton with
concern when we cut back we see a
close-up of the audits and family photo
but something else besides Emmitt
Otterton has gone missing look closely
there is no purse hanging from mrs.
Otterton arm in the close-up then after
another shot of judy there's a wide shot
of mrs. Otterton
and her purse is back on her arm either
the police team is able to solve the
case of the missing person record time
or they just forgot to include the purse
in the close-up frozen frozen is a tale
of two sisters who rescue one another
with the power of love and ice a whole
lot of ice when Anna and Kristoff and
Olaf ventured to Elsa's ice palace to
ask Elsa to reverse the internal winter
in arendelle things take an unexpected
turn Elsa accidentally freezes on his
heart then Elsa creates a giant snow
monster with the adorable name
marshmallow however it turns out he's
nice adorable as his name he throws Anna
Kristoff and Olaf out of the palace and
they slide down the ice staircase that's
when we notice an animation mistake in
the previous scenes anna is wearing a
hat but while she is sliding down the
stairs her hat is gone after she and
Kristoff win to the pile of snow at the
bottom of the stairs on his hat is back
on her head again so was it just too
time-consuming and tricky to add the hat
to the scene or did they forget it's
such a fast-moving sequence it's
possible they hoped the audience
catch it The Incredibles in the original
Incredibles movie poor Bob is a
superhero with incredible strength who
is forced to work a boring desk job at
an insurance company due to the
government superhero relocation program
all supers had to turn in their capes
and act like ordinary people to prevent
lawsuits so Bob is a giant man who sits
behind the tiny desk and tries to help
little old ladies with insurance claims
and Bob works for a tiny greedy mean
little man Bob gets in trouble with his
boss for helping the old lady and is
called into his office during the scene
Bob sees a woman being mugged outside of
the office window so Bob shuts the door
releasing his grasp on the mangled door
handle that buckled from his rage grip
but before Bob commits aggravated
assault there's an animation mistake
that we picked up on when Bob is sitting
on his boss's desk the office doors
closed behind him but later when Bob
gets up to save the lady in the street
from the mugger we never see the door
beam opens but bob has the doorknob from
the open door in his hand Finding Nemo
the movie Finding Nemo changed the way
kids viewed fish and fish tanks
relearn's that fish really don't like it
when kids bang on the glass all drains
lead to the ocean and that anything is
possible
animation mistakes are even possible in
this film in fact we found two
continuity errors that are worth
mentioning both of them take place in
the dentist's office
the first mistake occurs when the
dentist is preparing to give Nemo to his
niece Darla she is the Braceface kid who
bangs on the glass of the fish tank and
wouldn't stop shaking the bag of her
last fish you can imagine the horror of
Nemo and his fish tank pals at the idea
of Nemo becoming Darla's next victim
the dentist scoops Nemo up in a plastic
bag and sets him on the counter but if
you look closely the bag changes from a
ziplock bag to a normal bag and he ties
it at the top and there's more during
the scene when the Pelican Nigel swims
to the dentist's office there's another
oops moment look at the wall in the back
there's no picture on the wall when
Nigel is in the office but when he flies
out of the window there's an alligator
poster wreck-it Ralph record Ralph is
the story about the triumph of
friendship
it follows Ralph a bad guy in a video
game who wants to get a medal
so he can be a hero but Ralph
accidentally crashes a space pod into
the game sugar rush releasing an alien
bug and compromising the safety of the
entire arcade Ralph meets vanellope von
schweetz a character in the sugar rush
game who has a bit of a glitch problem
together they can take the game back
from the evil king candy who stole the
crown from the rightful princess
vanellope herself King candy is actually
turbo from a malfunctioning game that
had its plug pulled he hijacked sugar
rush and caused a lot of trouble in that
game but when they defeated King candy
slash turbo everything in sugar rush
seemed to be back to normal princess
vanellope was back in her princess dress
complete with a licorice crown and candy
scepter balance is restored and all as
well with no trace of King candy right
who well almost
if you look for Heinz vanellope and
Ralph you'll see King Candy's initials
on the front of the candy stands that
probably should have changed to pv for
princess vanellope what you knew is
paradise who would want to go anywhere
Moana Moana is a heartwarming tale of a
village Chiefs daughter who was drawn to
the ocean she goes on a voyage across
the sea to save the people on her small
Polynesian island but before she
journeys away to distant lands meets an
arrogant demigod named Maui and restores
the heart of defeat II she must make it
off the islands this is a task that has
proven to be quite challenging as her
father forbids her from getting on a
boat in one scene a frustrated Moana
sits tossing sticks into the sand before
sharing a heartfelt moment with her
mother of course this is a perfect
opportunity for her to break into song
as all Disney Princesses must do Moana
sings about staring at the edge of the
water for as long as she can remember as
Moana is singing her powerful ballad we
see the sand behind her is free from
those sticks she was throwing earlier
maybe hey hey the chicken ate them who
knows are there any animation mistakes
we missed if so tell us about them in
the comments and don't forget to
subscribe to the things channel to be
the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]